welcome to this video for round seven of
the candidates tournament and it's under
akin playing white against Apollo yeah I
dragon having a pretty miserable
tournament not winning a single game yet
and he even was in trouble and some of
the drawers you think against the game
against Allen this was tough but ok it
was not totally lost but yeah he's not
having a great tournament and T'Pol off
to be honest also doesn't have a good
one he's got on 50 he's got fifty
percent now by beating Cromley guests
today out of some dangerous preparation
where kramnik really fell apart in the
opening series on fifty percent which is
not really great if you want to qualify
so he needs to win some games for sure
to catch up with Arnold enter aronian
yeah let's see what's happened here yeah
we get to a Queens gambit declined and
yeah it's a bit of a you're not in
surprising choice but by tomorrow but so
could maybe a reckon with something a
bit more confrontational let's say Kings
Indian or whatever to to risk something
but ok is playing am playing the Queens
gambit declined um it would have been
interesting to see what you would have
done after Knight c3 probably see six to
go to the semi Slav to get a fighting
position it's a bit more interesting
than there should be seven for example
but this said didn't happen because
under 18 now playing Bishop to g5 yeah
this is a somewhat of a spirit yeah of a
special cannot pronounce that speciality
something that he's playing as some
surprise weapon here and down
he beat them chronic with this move last
year Dortmund and Reagan has very good
score against chronic he's got a plus go
if i'm not mistaken yeah and this move
Bishop g5 is it's quite interesting it
especially interesting if black is not
intending to go to to a classical
variation with Bishop e7 if black plays
Bishop e7 we pretty much almost all the
time will transpose to let's say here
the lusca oops on take over variation
but ok this was certainly not into
polyps interest if you want to have a
somewhat sharper battle you need to do
something else okay you can play c6 as
mentioned it is maybe a what the
powerful wanted to do in case of 93 but
here why does not need to play this
movie can for instance also play Quincy
to with an interesting game and far less
sharp yeah the polyp let h6 this is
another idea against this early Bishop
g5 that deserves attention the main idea
is that now white cannot so easily play
Bishop h4 you can but after Bishop
Sankey form it gets somewhat tricky um
no 93 is in fact a bit questionable
because I'm black can be I can't play
various things but one of them is in
fact this kind of this kind of stuff
which is very sharp and with h5 going
something like that attending age for
winning the winning the bishop yeah it's
quite quite strange but interesting for
black Bishop h4s it's not considered to
be really good he took on f6 this also
happened in the game against Kramnik
last year and now night BTW to one of
the
ideas of this setup you have not
committed the night yet to see three so
night vd2 as possible this shouldn't be
something too brilliant I mean the night
on d 2 is not overwhelmingly well placed
but it leads to Alex plot play that
Scylla some Sally complicated yeah
chronic played g6 and disposition and
Ben fianchetto which is very similar to
the Moscow variation of the semi sloth
but Topalov plays another great Bishop
e7 I'm not a move that at least for my
taste look so natural with somehow we
are cutting off the Queen's natural
retweet square but it turns out to be
quite a good setup p now played Quincy
21 Dragan I'm not so sure if ya or how
White's player can be improved improved
upon because only very quickly black
gets a good position here c5 to pull
offs got the pair of bishops this is
nice to have and he tries to quickly
open up the center will see 5 yeah to be
honest I'm already I already think that
black has a very comfortable game here
maybe am III Quincy to his combination
of Musa didn't really fit so well
especially the Queen on c2 we would see
now why yeah what is why it's supposed
to do now draken took on c5 um here also
I could have taken on d5 another
possibility here black ken amongst
others simply recapture this is also an
idea but simply taking here is good
takes and Bishop ecigs ya know black is
going to play rook c8 and then get at
the c5 with c5 pawn something like that
for example
something like that is already a very
good for black history already has got
the bishops and the good development if
you give them something like that let's
say here it gets a get serious already
like it's very very much better here
it's it's already a bit tricky it took
on c5 and no 97 was played yeah which is
a fine move but also not a six was a
possibility this gives the additional
idea for what to take but ok 97's not to
be criticized why took on d5 yet here's
the first spot where the part of could
have made things a bit easier let's say
he's playing he's playing in a very
complicated fashion pretty much typical
of his style but 95 was an interesting
alternative he recaptured on d5 but 95
Islam it's just ok for black out I mean
ok I think what black is somewhat better
to be honest if widest greedy and
captures upon it is really a great
development for black something like
that was even mentioned in the press
conference here and to par love in this
position gave the light eform Bishop h7
with compensation that's true Black has
compensation the computer however even
comes up with this move and I takes
deform and blankets just winning or now
winning is too much but black is
certainly better here the idea is this
position where of course this Hanks and
there's also Queen g2 and this is now
very very tough to defend if what wants
to keep the night here what are you
going to do after that no and you don't
really have anything like that so is g2a
why doesn oops supposed to be too much
why this is
after that here in big trouble big
trouble um yeah I'm not sure maybe why
should play a yeah a quiet move here
like that and then try to do castle but
this Bishop f5 already mom maybe this
first and here yeah Black has a good
good game IAM 96 for example fighting
for this he's just very quick with
developing and he's got two bishops why
them of course can can claim that the
isolated d5 pawn is the weakness but
yeah that's not so important 95 was a
simple solution he took on d5 with the
porn not a bad move not a bad move but
it is it is simpler to just take on c5
with the night okay night be three wide
is keeping the sport for the moment and
now a five this was obviously the idea
yeah if white now it's not playing a for
like and Reagan did um yeah if it's not
doing that black would simply regain the
porn with good play let's say something
like that oops here and now it takes
yeah this is just comfortable for black
but hmm I was just thinking how good is
this really yeah comparison with a for
the thing is he played a four and maybe
maybe you should have actually avoided a
four if I now think of it yeah the
position that I dash that I shown a
couple of moments ago like in this
position that's certainly I'm very okay
for black but I actually would prefer
that SS as whites to the game yeah well
in breaking played it in a very sharp
man i played a form just stopping a5 a4
and yeah this
leads to a very very complicated play
which I'm not sure about really topalov
played b6 this is good basically the
only move to justify all that and then
raking is playing c6 advancing the pawn
that's also the only move you cannot
take one b6 for example this just opens
up all the floodgates I mean black would
say here then here get the porn back at
have an overwhelming position and c6
it's just better getting this pawn to c6
very strong pawn yeah now this check
yeah and TM white really doesn't have
much of a choice you don't want to put
your nights in a pin here let's say
let's say this for example and there is
again this possibility and widest and in
big trouble note that you won't even
keep the pawn this is even more clumsy
and sink yeah with a good game for black
you play King you on not not nice but
again that was necessary 95 and I to
deform this was a position that under
akin went off went for aimed for any
played a form and yeah but i'm not i'm
not really i'm not really sure the thing
is that is obviously a very very sharp
white is 1 upon this pollen c6 which
also limits black's pieces in some way
and the pawn can also be always
protected by this should be 5 on the
other hand what is your keen doing on d1
not not a pretty sight um however
there's one feature of the position that
is very much in whites favor the
position is easier for why to play
simply because of the fact that why its
next move are pretty self-evident you
will go as already shown in the picture
you will put your bishop on b5 to sue to
secure the pawn
and the next idea is to walk the King
over to a tune and on a 2 it is
relatively safe in the same time it's
not so clear what black should do I mean
it is clear that you should have some
kind of compensation this is a nice
piece for example now you can maybe get
this pawn back at some point and the
king is not great on you want but what
exactly are you going to play I think
that the computer suggestion here is in
fact a very good one the computer wants
to play Bishop g4 am now Houdini would
uniform the idea is that after we should
be five you're going to go night to e6
and what this basically does is fighting
for this blockade square and if you
manage to lift the blockade from deform
you may be at the end we'll get to the
king something like that for example
just to me to show and then intending to
play d4 at some point this is I believe
completely unclear I mean have no idea
how to judge this position it's just
very messy but we have I mean blackest
black as I think in reasonable shape the
porn on c6 is not going to promote any
time soon and while you have played the
part of when to e form again with the
night not fighting for default just lets
this night on d4 stay there the his idea
was entirely different and we see that
in the game we should be five g5 this
was the polo's idea a very very
aggressive advance um yeah he intends to
push g4 and get to the f2 pawn um yeah
it's an understandable I mean it's easy
to understand the plan but it seems that
ultimately this is flawed because of um
yeah relatively simple idea to be honest
I am very surprised that he went went
for this s it is not so difficult to
too plain our done Drake and played he
played h3 ok this is a kind of knee-jerk
reaction almost you don't want to allow
a simply g4 yeah it took all of late age
five and I think after that to be honest
that's that's that's gone after age five
you cannot save like anymore it's just
too weak g5 and h5 the problem is that
the general idea that he has g-force is
that simply not working drinking now
played king see one you are completing
this this plan and the problem is black
cannot play G form that was the whole
point of everything but you now simply
ignore all that is why this is the
problem you can take the night here but
how are you going to ever survive this
position with the route coming to g1
this is just deadly white would have a
deadly attack here black has completely
exposed as king this is the problem the
the whole idea is something that white
can simply allow age five and g4 and
after that you're getting yeah black is
getting himself mated and not vice versa
and yeah the thing is okay you cannot
play g4 what are you playing yeah he
played um Bishop c5 king be one this was
this was clear still you cannot play g4
and if you cannot do that what what is
flex plan he's got all pieces misplaced
now there is nothing like Bishop g4 or
any kind of piece play yeah he played
rook e8 King a tune and now Luke a7 yeah
it's it does not look brilliant but what
is black supposed to do you White has a
perfect lo que Don defore this is
covered and there's no way really to to
make any sort of progress rook to d1
king of a bit of a mysterious move to be
honest but I think tapada was already
pretty desperate he didn't we couldn't
really find an idea
look H to f1 covering here so that maybe
you can move the night and push the f
porn it went back with the King King a 1
i'm not so sure about that miss me but
it's not any any problem White has
really adds lots of time Bishop f8 and
now 92 yeah now we see the final point
yeah maybe he played King a 1 because
there should be six years you didn't
want to allow any sort of default check
threats we see now the final point white
is going to play age form and make sure
that f4 is available for the night and
this happened h4 an idea and this is
just just terrible power plate King g8 I
need to switch off this messages kingi
eight and nine takes d5 yeah and here to
part of just resigned its everything's
falling apart and go here yeah you can
even take you form and check get the
Queen back here with the fork yeah
there's a multiple ways to win yeah it
looks like a complete disaster this game
for to pull off it's simply this this
idea g5 h5 or simply totally 40 it looks
I mean black must play aggressively it
cannot just sit sit and wait in this
position but it simply seems like to be
the wrong plan for the further for the
simple fact that if you really if you
even realize it it doesn't do anything
because you open up your own king yeah
so at the end a pretty drastic loss form
to Paolo who is back on minus one after
after this game so he lost two games won
this game certainly an important win
firm against Kramnik but for the whole
tournament standings he's on minus one
and basically out of it it's very hard
to
that he would be able to catch up to the
to the leaders he would need to win
three games just to be even with the
honor before the round you consider that
very tough to believe that you can you
can do that um yeah and I'm Drake in
escort his first win certainly important
for him he yeah he's a player with not
so much experience on the absolute
highest level he is played and won the
russian championships for example and
stuff like that but this is simply a the
ultimate test this kind of tournament
here just top players double round-robin
very tough and it's certainly important
for him to have won a game in the first
turn of this event and minus one is to
be honest not a bad score I mean
certainly this is the kind of tournament
the only first place really counts but
okay terms of rating for example
middle-earth minus one he is simply
gaining rating points he's playing a
buffis expected score so it's not like
he's doing something something terrible
yeah all right I hope you enjoyed this
game thanks for watching